foreign
why is it so slow
Margaret why is it so slow
your energetic component
for and or your spiritual components
they're not
they're not theoretical things
they have real world effects
just because they're not Material
doesn't mean they're not that they're
hence theoretical
and the skill of releasing
is equally
not theoretical
it's not on
intellectually
understood thing
and it's not
a utilization of the imagination the
imagination is not real
you're you can't imagine anything it
will not have a realistic impact
on reality
do you not
also trying to relax and release and
de-stress
you're not trying to get comfortable
these this is all
it just categorically because
it's not real has no impact
you have to try for different things
you can't try for what modernity tells
you it is in modernity in its history of
materiality it has
made you too weak
to unwise
to understand what is going on so if you
try to understand it with your modern
mind you're just
doing
you just imagining de-stressing
huh
doing your stupid goat yoga and your hot
yoga studio
that that's not it
I don't have to go
I just moved my hands in in the
energetic pattern
move his time then if you go in that
[Music]
foreign
at the energetic component
you have to train there you can't train
at your imagination
or your intellect
or what the Western World tells you
you're supposed to be doing when you're
spiritual
the Western world is wrong
it's real stuff
it's not hot yoga
so you have to stop doing
the other stuff you just have to take it
off the table
I I'm not going to go
here and Guru
says
oh
I that
that's not it
it's not it
it's real stuff not imagine stuff
not imagine stuff
you have to know your aspect again so
yeah if I if I win
I am
you're going to have a lot of yielding
you see and then
not pushing directly into the target
okay almost
almost
okay you just have the front part
so a win
yeah yep come back okay so here fire
right first you see
wind
Jesus
this on the surface of the tongue
foreign
[Music]
it's about not projecting as deep
okay so in other words my hand is here
push my head
we're not going anywhere you could
always project you see but just on the
surface here this way you feel that
again it's not about even yining y'all
can't do it here you just do it on the
surface
if you understand can you see what I'm
saying so you can uh bring him into the
Tilt and now here's the problem don't
pushed here
brush toss his tunde
and what I'm saying is you can do it
here brush past this time
when
you you get triggered by his weight but
instead his weight is telling you
where to brush pass okay as opposed to
it triggers me and now I want to push
it out of the way okay
all right
you hear me
again it's an energetic drill so as I
grab
and I do the prescribed spinal
penetration I am generating my content
field and her Tom denfield you feel that
this is different
okay
oh this is different too that's
different
a time to generate young energy
right and then as I do that your young
energy comes back into me and now I have
my time didn't feel and it's
simultaneously generates your tandem
field you see so if I stay here we will
be pressurized you see that and if I
wanted to uh move you I rotate my
content fields
don't need the grips or anything that's
not the taunted field is here and once
once I stay equal to you within the it
manifest itself you feel the friction
and so that's what it's moving okay
but I have a prescribed role as UK after
I generated our tonden fields that I now
hold mine still
and let you turn it okay do you
understand that so you're you do the
technique and I'm not going to turn my
field do you see that so you're like
here and then I go over here I turn my
feet
I hold my field still
and you have to turn my field
okay
you have to turn your field to turn my
field
together
generate it again
so this you do you feel that so right so
right now that Tandon look that tonden
that I generated do you see when you
when you let your hand go here
you see and you collapsed that aren't
that arms collapsed it's not that it's
close to you that's not what makes it
collapse is that you separated it from
your tandem field and now the adhesion
is on your body do you see that and so
what you did is you tried to push on it
and you're we're not going anywhere okay
so again you're here generate the field
you feel the field okay so I can come
back here do you see anything push on it
and I can still move you
you see I don't I don't want to go
collapse and then try to get back off of
there there's no need for that okay and
that's what you did is when you felt
that it collapsed it freaked you out and
you try to push on it okay but instead
pull and you just turn the tandoned
field
where'd it go
let's let it collapse again and you go
I know I don't give it back to you
because I would have to take my Tom
denfield off okay so you collapsed again
where you take this arm out I don't turn
my content field on my own
okay so making making stuff like this
let's go that way making this stuff
do you see that okay
oh and uh
again to do it internally I'm I can't
this is not this is no field here
generated everything is blocked in my
shoulders okay so I'm very I'm very
relaxed you see
very relaxed and at any moment I can I
can do the technique from Lucas point
okay
but I don't because I lose it so I do
cookie dosa
which is the rotating of my taunted
fields on that rotating cross pattern
but from the yin point of view you're
gonna rotate
you're so you're just leaning to me
that's all you're doing you're leaning
me leaning me you see leaning me
and then the battery there will turn
themselves exactly
but you want to hold the relationship
so I'll lean you if I want to but then I
have to rotate it I have to rotate it my
field rotates then your field rotates to
see
it's not it's not about my hands because
that's you're doing your hands but
you're just taking the time Midfield
back in and out so my condent has to
rotate oh
see if you can feel it okay oh wrong I'm
gonna just jiggle it okay
oh
okay
that's it
good
okay that was very good
foreign